I would like to start by talking with
you both about this approach that you've
taken in shooting your last three films
that you've made together the Dallas
buyers club wild and and now demolition
how has we could you talk a little bit
about the style that you've been using
the approach and how it's evolved over
these films or how it stayed the same or
it started on Dallas buyers club well
earlier on cafe Lafleur I was shooting
with down syndrome kids and they were
affected by the spots and the flags and
reflectors and so I asked the DP to get
rid of everything I asked the crew to
get out of the set and I started to
shoot available light with a red camera
with Vanessa Paradis with the actress
and the Down syndrome kids and and then
I realized it was possible to get rid of
the crew oh my god we can do that and
then I looked at the dailies and it was
beautiful it looked like I was in a
cinema in Paris watching other dailies
and it looked like I had a cinema
experience and it was a read no film
grain you know film look has been
applied yet so so since Dallas buyers
club we didn't have we didn't have a lot
of money we made the film with 4.9
million and so I told the producers in
my to let's shoot wouldíve with this
approach available light we can well ask
the crew again I will shoot 360 degrees
and no reflector no it doesn't block the
light he doesn't reflect it and and and
it became it became it became a style a
style that we're not pushing ahead we're
not aiming for style we aim for
storytelling emotion we observe we don't
interfere try to not interfere you know
we don't Dali in if we down on the end
it's to follow a cab
and try to design the shots with the
main characters and and I must say he
has the courage to do that and he
controls the Alex on so well and and III
you know I I push him out of his comfort
zone asking my always to try to show
that to or under - so there's no depth
of feeling you want to take over so here
you're following the the the actors
aren't blocked ahead of time you're more
just following the action as it's as as
yet no there's no rear so at all I'm
Dallas we would like look with a
viewfinder a little bit and no wet it's
gonna happen but now we're like we don't
know what the actor is gonna do and
everything it's it's tougher for the
focus puller than me I would say but
yeah but what is this it's it's great
because this first idea was because of
an economic economic reason you know we
didn't have time and money for lights
and for Dallas but it becomes kind of an
aesthetics it's variant I still learn
it's because you don't think about it
but as a similar effort you always kind
of control and when you shoot a little
light there's a lot of effects that
happen in the face of the actors that
you're usually if you put already a key
light it arrays it and there's so many
secondary lights that happens in real
life or you know the fact that the
lights coming from window are a lot of
times balanced on green so the light is
greener if you're in the beach it's it's
warmer and things like that and it's fun
to play with that and but I could only
do that with John Mac and with the Alexa
camera I don't trust the other camera
for this kind of shoot and I don't trust
that her director on the job okay to do
that to shoot a little light Brian can
you tell us a little bit about where
this story and these characters came
from sure I did demolition work when I
was probably 17 ty was 21 years old and
I was working for my father mostly these
houses that had burned so I was on the
crew that had to go in and tear the
house down before they started
rebuilding it so there are a couple of
things that happened I learned
you know once you tear everything apart
you tear the walls down you tear the
ceiling down you see the framework of
the house and I remember thinking okay I
get it like this is how it's all put
together I couldn't build it but I think
I just sort of processed that
that metaphor even as a younger man who
who didn't have any ambition of becoming
a writer or anything and then the other
thing was I sort of lost myself you know
I was standing around in these these
burned out houses breathing in the
insulation and the char and and thinking
this this is not the life that I want
you know I gotta find a way out of this
and I did and I and then I I came to Los
Angeles and it was it was all so manual
labor you know starting to trying to
become a screenwriter and and and then I
found myself in a very similar place you
know five six years later where it just
wasn't working who you know and I was
just I was failing and I'm working in a
bar and I don't have any money and and I
don't know what my voice is anymore I
don't know what the town wants I don't
know how to pay my rent anymore and I
slipped into that that similar place it
was when I was doing demolition work you
know and that that apathy that I was
feeling and and from that was the voice
of this character and he basically
started speaking to me you know and his
voice got a little bit louder and then
there was this world created and these
other characters and there's
relationships and it was just something
that I was cathartic diving into it and
giving him the sledgehammer and let him
letting him destroy things
well Judah it's always great to see and
and introducing credit at the end of a
movie and it must be great to see your
name below that that credit can you tell
us a little bit about how you got the
role and and started to actually work on
the on the film yeah I initially self
taped for it I'm actually
and I you know sent auditions back and
forth a few times and got some notes and
then I ended up skyping with jean-marc
and and we Skyped for I think like two
hours and you know we really worked
through the material and and talked
about the character and the film and the
one thing was music was you know is very
instrumental in the film and it's kind
of his his way of expressing himself and
so jean-marc made made a playlist of six
or seven songs and he and he had me
dance to them and I mean it ranged from
like R&B to rock to you know about the
most contradictory genres and and you
know and I'm not a dancer but but but
you know it wasn't about the
technicality
it was really about the feeling and the
feeling of absolutely letting go and
really just putting yourself out there
you bring up the the music that is such
an important part of this film that I
wanted to ask for us about how how you
how you whether the songs came first or
whether the scenes came first I mean
that's always such an interesting you
know question that I have as a movie
goers when you're watching a scene and
there's a song in it and it fits so
perfectly you ask yourself well was the
scene conceived with that song in mind
or did somehow lightning strike at a
miracle occurred and the right song
landed in you know and fit perfectly
together like a puzzle piece with that
scene the issue that we had
production-wise was there was a song
written in the screenplay that was a big
factor and crazy on you I mean there's a
factor so we had to have it and as
anybody knows that tries to get rights
to this kind of stuff a song like that
that is so well known and and and has
been for so long it's still probably
being played every summer some arena
those are expensive and so in a
moderately budgeted movie like this well
that takes a big chunk of your
flexibility right off the top and so
jean-marc was really under
I think a tremendous burden because he
loves wild wallet no score all that kind
of stuff and so there were a lot of
songs to pick besides that one so it was
that a deal breaker that that heart song
had to be yeah well it's he wrote it I
mean it was it was in the mind from my
first reaction it's funny because I
challenged Brian about it because I
didn't like this it's not about liking
the song I think let's pick it you it's
not a say though and it's funny how I
got to learn to love this song and now I
never get it out of your head and now
and how I had fun in the cutting room
and even on set with Drake and with this
song and and then it's always you know
trying to find the right tracks for the
characters making playlists for them so
Davis wasn't into music but we as Brian
said Chris Judas character was the music
the music element the music was it was
the one that was now well that will give
us motivation to to bring music into
into this film and and and there's no
score and you know I'd like to do that
through just use music that is in the
story the characters are playing music
sometimes I cheat and it becomes score
and and and alright the characters are
not like hearing the music anymore but
it's rare you know most of the time we
cut in because there's a song playing
and their living room or in the kitchen
and he's always listening to music is
kind of her and the mother also Karen is
listening to music into music David's
wife Julia was had a thing for Sufjan
Stevens and classical music and so it's
trying to find music that will help us
tell this story and make it look real
and have so many more music is so
powerful and it conveys emotions that
it's
that and not even with the lyrics to
mess with with the melody and and yeah
and the way that the characters are you
catch them humming melodies or
whispering lyrics it's really it's
really quite effective well in how do
you pick a song to destroy a house -
were there a lot of contenders for that
- Judah how do you destroy a house most
effectively the song worked so how did
the the actual the demolition work go
yeah that that was my first day on set
that was your first day my first day I
mean yeah no I mean I walked on the set
and was handed a sledgehammer
that was I know what I love about that
scene though is is everything's real I
mean there's no breakaway glass or it's
so safe of course but you know
everything that you see happen me and
Jake actually did which which was
craziness kind of thing you never think
you're gonna be standing on one side of
a room and somebody's gonna tell you to
just throw a crowbar into a TV but it
happened and and you know the song
actually it's sung by M ward that was we
actually played that through the house
as well
demolishing it so that definitely played
a huge role well thank you all for
joining us tonight
and thank you for thank you thanks thank
you for coming